I'm glad they're doing that because
they're the ones that are gonna inherit
the planet and we're in a very difficult
situation in the moment especially in
the US where all the environmental
controls that were put in place that
perhaps with just about adequate say for
the last ten years have being rolled
back by the current administration so
much that they're all been wiped out so
so in the US which is should be the
world leader environment controllers go
as is lost that Nina's decided to go the
other way and I'm glad that people feel
so strongly about it they want to
protest anywhere wears a red carpet or
in place so yeah absolutely billing them
they have to fight harder and they have
to get as much support as they can and
the same thing I understood that there
were also people with respect to
immigration out front yeah
they to need every support that they can
look that that they can muster but all
of you when you're my age you know when
you're 85 years old and you have
children and grandchildren you believe
them nothing if we do not vote those
people out of office in Brazil in London
in Washington they are ruining the world
I mean we have contributed to the
ruination of it but they are insuring
you
you